what's up everybody is quite well and
I'm going undercover on the Internet
it's actually me this is actually me
Twitter quite low dropping a solo album
soon just wait on it quick thought but
what if the amigos at Drake drop a
collab may say after the tour
you must be a psychic and then I'll tell
you something I don't know what tell you
how does clay both look so good
literally all the time this is GQ you
just got to stay fresh and keep it clean
and God blessed me with great looks
thank you cuz you're beautiful yourself
yes sir
am I the only one hype about this Latin
artists like bad bunny Farouk Oh as I
said and now luma
I love working with international
artists it show you how big music
stretch if I'm speaking my bars in
English and they're speaking their bars
in their language and the people still
understand all that once and what song
they can hear and I look and it makes
the song and make people come together
they make the record a lot bigger submit
Cory why do the amigos always say screw
any songs
that's either a Lambo either we getting
away from 12
that's our sound screw ski what does
booze you mean amigo song bad and booze
fancy - super super fancy don't you can
be fancy but you bougie is just being
extra over-the-top what's quite well a
good quarterback when he played in high
school yes I was you can look on the
records I broke the records and still
holding today shoutouts we go in that
County on the no Bert Mar Patriots we in
the building
uh what does honcho me honcho me lead
other team once we won't bring back the
food to the family the one who put all
the weight on his shoulders gonna stick
his neck out there first that's what the
on show me seriously is actually me
ready this is for me he just had a good
talk with the flame Astro Boy
Oh honcho Jack - maybe maybe not but the
conversation was a great conversation
you - I wonder what the real me goes
think when they watch the S&L I thought
it was funny I love when everybody get
together and try to imitate us cuz that
cuz we got the most swag I know
everybody want to be yourself go ahead
and just dress up and be like us on
Halloween I'm I sell all the Mego
costumes the best one of my get my style
chain from your boy you did next
question that says that very well coming
in the back of working me know that's me
your boy if you see cobalt on any song
and no features as me touching
everything for production make sense to
the whole song and including the video
post it Yahoo Answers since migos and
cheap keep change to the rap games for
every what do you think what happened if
they never existed it wouldn't be a lot
of young rappers running around with
face tattoos jumping up and down going
crazy I think the youth will be lost
because we they big brothers back to
Twitter so much Twitter
yo is dead away to watch close flag
football game next year will be it's
gonna be streaming live right now we're
trying to figure out what channel which
station so just be on the lookout next
year and we do got family but I got mad
at my camera magazine get enough detail
so next year we will be on it this will
say does anyone else think that amigos
seems like they would be really for like
dinner gifts we do got manners at the
table but we like southern food and the
way we like our food
just cook special like we like
everything cooked crispy well done so we
gonna hit you with a lot of details on
how we like our food cook at the dinner
table I asked her all your questions
hope you got everything out of me that
you want it it's over with game over we
go